SOCIALISTS AOC LEVELING
BOMBSHELL ALLEGATIONS ON
CONDITIONS THAT MIGRANT
DETENTION CENTERS AFTER SHE
JOINED A GROUP OF HOUSE
DEMOCRATS WHO VISITED TWO
DETENTION FACILITIES IN
TEXAS YESTERDAY.
THE CONGRESSWOMAN EVEN
REPORTEDLY SCREAMING AT
BORDER AGENTS AT ONE STOP.
HERE ARE THE EXPLOSIVE
CLAIMS SHE IS MAKING ABOUT
THE TREATMENT OF THOSE
MIGRANTS.
>> THERE IS ABUSE IN THESE
FACILITIES.
THERE IS ABUSE.
THIS IS THEM ON THEIR BEST
BEHAVIOR AND THEY PUT THEM
IN ROOMS WITH NO RUNNING
WATER, AND THESE WOMEN WERE
BEING TOLD BY CBP OFFICERS
TO DRINK OUT OF THE TOILET.
THEY WERE DRINKING WATER OUT
OF THE TOILET.
THAT WAS THEM KNOWING A
CONGRESSIONAL VISIT WAS
COMING.
THIS IS CBP ON THEIR BEST
BEHAVIOR TELLING PEOPLE TO
DRINK OUT OF THE TOILET.
>> DID YOU SEE SOMEBODY
ACTUALLY DOING THAT?
>> I MEAN, IN THAT LAST
FACILITY, I WAS NOT SAFE
FROM THE OFFICERS IN THAT
FACILITY.
>> Jesse: BORDER PATROL
ISSUING A HARSH REBUTTAL TO
THE FRESHMAN CONGRESSWOMAN
FIRING BACK SAYING THE
ACCUSATIONS ARE NOT TRUE.
>> I CAN TELL YOU WITH THE
UTMOST CONFIDENCE THAT THE
MIGRANTS, ANYONE AND
EVERYONE IN OUR CUSTODY AT
ALL OF OUR FACILITIES HAVE
READY ACCESS TO FRESH WATER.
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO
CONSUMERRABLES, AND THE
STANDARDS THAT WE APPLY TO
MAKE SURE THAT ON A
RECURRING AND VERY TIMED
BASIS THAT NOT ONLY THEY
HAVE ACCESS TO THE TYPES OF
CONSUMABLES AND FRESH WATER
THEY WOULD NEED.
I HAVE NEVER HEARD IN 26
YEARS OF BEING IN THIS
BUSINESS EVER HEARD OF THAT
TYPE OF ALLEGATION BEING
MADE.
>> Jesse: GREG, DO YOU
BELIEVE HER?
>> I WOULD ACTUALLY BE --
NEED TO SEE SOME PROOF TO
THIS.
I THINK IT'S JUST HER BEING
SNEAKY.
BECAUSE I DON'T BELIEVE --
THIS IS MY GUT IS THAT NO
ONE HAS BEEN DRINKING FROM
ANY TOILET.
BUT IF YOU SEE THAT THE
WATER FOUNTAIN IS SITUATED
ABOVE THE TOILET FOR
PLUMBING REASONS IN
EMERGENCY SHELTER AND OFTEN
IN CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES
YOU WILL SEE THAT YOU WILL
SEE THE TOILET AND FOR
PLUMBING REASONS BECAUSE
THAT'S WHERE THE PLUMBING
COMES OUT OF.
THE WATER SOURCE IS BELOW.
IT'S NOT TOILET WATER.
IT'S DRINKING WATER BUT IT'S
ABOVE THE TOILET.
BUT SHE IS CLEVER BECAUSE
SHE JUST BROADLY SAYS THEY
ARE DRINKING FROM THE
TOILET.
AND PEOPLE CAN GO LIKE YEAH,
BECAUSE THE TOILET IS THERE.
SO I THINK THAT WHAT SHE DID
WAS SAID SOMETHING THAT IS
FALSE BUT DIRECTIONALLY
TRUE.
LIKE SHE COULD GET AWAY FROM
IT.
BIGGER STORY IS HOW THE LEFT
HAS FREE PASS TO DEMONIZE
ANYONE.
WE HAVE SEEN ACCUSATIONS OF
CHILD ABUSE DIRECTED AT
PEOPLE WHO WORK THERE.
SHE SUGGESTED THAT THESE
GUYS MIGHT SEXUALLY ASSAULT
HER.
SHE DOESN'T FEEL SAFE AROUND
THEM.
THESE ARE HORRIBLE THINGS TO
SAY ABOUT PEOPLE CASUALLY TO
SAY THEM CASUALLY.
BUT IF YOU RESPOND ANGRILY
OR CRITICIZE HER SUDDENLY
SHE BECOMES THE VICTIM.
THESE ARE SNOWFLAKE BEARING
SWITCH BLADES THEY COME AT
YOU AND THE MOMENT YOU
RESPOND OH MY GOD, YOU HATE
ME.
AND IT IS KIND OF WEIRD IN
THE IRONY OF THIS WHOLE
THING IS THE LEFT
INCENTIVIZES THESE CRISES BY
EGGING ON TWO THINGS.
THE CARAVANS, THEY WERE
ENCOURAGED AS A WAY TO
OVERWHELM THE BORDER TO
CREATE VISUALS.
NEXT?
THEY WERE INVENT SIZED
THEY WERE INIENT SIZED
THEY WERE ININCT SIZED
THEY WERE ININCENSIZED
THEY WERE ININCENTIZED
THEY WERE ININCENTIVID
THEY WERE ININCENTIVIZED TO
BRING CHILDREN.
ACTIVISTS WERE TELLING IT'S
EASIER TO GET ACROSS THE
BORDER IF YOU BRING KIDS AND
DEMONIZE THE PEOPLE DEALING
WITH THIS INFLUX.
THE RESULT IS YOU HAVE MORE
SEXUAL ASSAULTS MORE
DROWNING AND MORE DEATHS.
THESE CENTERS ARE PROBABLY
THE BEST RELIEF THAT THESE
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO GET IN
THIS SITUATION AND THEY ARE
BEING DEMONIZED.
BY THE VERY PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCENTIVIZING IT.
>> Jesse: SHE VOTED TWICE
AGAINST BILLS THAT WOULD
HAVE PROVIDED MORE RESOURCES
AGAINST THESE MIGRANTS IN
THESE FACILITIES AND THEN
SHE GOES DOWN TO THE
FACILITY AND SAYS THEY ARE
NOT GETTING THE RIGHT
RESOURCES.
LOOKS PRETTY HYPOCRITICAL.
>> Juan: ARE YOU TALKING TO
ME?
>> Jesse: I'M TALKING TO
JUAN WILLIAMS.
>> Juan: ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT HAPPENS HERE WE CAN
POLITICIZE THIS AND I WOULD
JUST PREFER WE DO NOT DO
THAT I WILL SAY THIS.
THE BIG NEWS TO ME IS HAVE
THIS FACEBOOK PAGE GROUP,
BORDER PATROL AGENTS WHO
HAVE ABSOLUTELY SPOKEN IN
DEHUMANIZING TERMS ABOUT THE
MIGRANTS.
AND THEY HAVE ALSO MADE
AWFUL SEXUAL INNUENDO ABOUT
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ.
THE CONGRESSWOMAN.
AND NOW WE HAVE A DHS
INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT IN
WHICH THE INSPECTOR GENERAL,
JESSE SAYS THREE OF THE FIVE
STATIONS HAVE NO SHOWER FOR
CHILDREN.
KIDS HAVE NO CHANGE OF
CLOTHES AND NO WAY TO DO
LAUNDRY.
TWO OF THE STATIONS, TWO OF
THE FIVE HAVE NO HOT MEALS
FOR KIDS.
THESE ARE NOT GOOD
SITUATIONS.
AND IF YOU THEN UNDERSTAND
THE KIND OF VERY HOSTILE
RHETORIC THAT THE AGENTS
HAVE BEEN TAKING PART IN ON
THE FACEBOOK PAGE THEN FOR
THE CONGRESSWOMAN TO DO HER
DUTY, WHICH IS TO GO TO THAT
STATION AND TO INSPECT IT
AND TO SEE THE CONDITIONS
AND NOT JUST ENGAGE IN
POLITICAL RHETORIC IN
WASHINGTON BUT ACTUALLY GO,
I THINK SHE HAS A RIGHT TO
FEEL --
>> Greg: SHE DID NO
POLITICAL RHETORIC DOWN
THERE?
THAT WASN'T A PHOTO OP. WHEN
SHE INSULTED.
>> SHE DIDN'T INSULT.
>> Greg: THAT'S NOT
POLITICAL?
>> Juan: GREG, I WILL TELL
YOU WHAT WAS INSULTING THEM
TALKING ABOUT HER IN A
TOTALLY.
>> Greg: WE CAN GO INTO THAT
TOO.
SHE CALLED THEM CHILD
ABUSERS.
>> Jesse: THEY ARE RUNNING
CONCENTRATION CAMPS.
I THINK KATIE, WE ALL AGREE
WE WANT THE BEST FOR THESE
MIGRANTS.
HE WANT
WE WANT TO TAKE CARE OF THEM
THE BEST WE CAN.
THEY SHOULD NOT BE HERE AND
COME HERE THE WAY THEY CAME
HERE.
IT'S AN UNFORTUNATE
SITUATION.
THE BORDER PATROL AGENTS ARE
NOT TRAINED FOR THIS.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE
FACILITIES.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE MONEY.
THEY ARE DOING THE BEST THEY
CAN.
>> Katie: I'M GLAD SHE MADE
A REAL TRIP TO A DETENTION
CENTER TO A SHELTER INSTEAD
OF POSING FOR A PHOTO OP. IN
FRONT OF AN EMPTY PARKING
LOT FIRST TIME AROUND WITH
PHOTOGRAPHER AND FAKE
CRYING.
THAT'S THE FIRST STEP.
SECOND IS TOTALLY
FRAUDULENT.
VOTED AGAINST EVERY SINGLE
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT
WOULD HAVE AT LEAST EASED
THE SITUATION TEMPORARILY.
THE REASON WHY, JUAN, YOU
ARE SEEING A LACK OF
FACILITIES, A LACK OF FOOD,
A LACK OF CLOTHING FOR
CHILDREN IS BECAUSE THE
BORDER PATROL IS
OVERWHELMED.
THESE FACILITIES ARE MEANT
FOR MAYBE 1,000 PEOPLE.
THERE ARE 4 OR 5,000 PEOPLE
WHO ARE CROWDING.
>> Greg: HOW DID THAT
HAPPEN?
>> Katie: THAT IS HAPPENING
BECAUSE CONGRESS AND PEOPLE
LIKE AOC CONTINUE TO USE
THIS AS A POLITICAL TALKING
POINT INSTEAD OF SOLVING THE
PROBLEM.
WHEN WAYFAIR SOLD BEDS TO
THE BORDER PATROL TO HAVE
BEDS FOR CHILDREN WHO DIDN'T
HAVE THEM, SHE LED A BOYCOTT
AND SAID THEY SHOULDN'T BE
SELLING BEDS TO CHILDREN AND
THEN SHE GOES DOWN THERE AND
SAYS WHY DON'T ANY OF THESE
CHILDREN HAVE ANY BEDS?
IT'S COMPLETELY
DISINGENUOUS.
THE FACT IS THIS CAN BE
FIXED.
IF YOU WANT TO BE PART OF
THE SOLUTION YOU JUST DON'T
GO DOWN AND CALL THE BORDER
PATROL SEXUAL ASSAULTERS,
SEXUAL PREDATORS, NAZIS YOU
VOTE FOR THINGS THAT MAKE IT
BETTER.
>> Jesse: SOME OF THE
WITNESSES DOWN THERE, DANA,
ACCORDING TO THE WASHINGTON
EXAMINER SHE WENT AND
STARTED YELLING AND
SCREAMING AT THE BORDER
PATROL OFFICERS.
REFUSED A TOUR OF THE
FACILITY AND
MISCHARACTERIZED THE
CONVERSATION SHE HAD WITH
THE DETAINEES.
>> Dana: IT IS PRETTY
ASTONISHING THAT YOU CAN
HAVE SEVERAL PEOPLE ALL
SAYING WHAT SHE SAID ABOUT
DRINKING WATER OUT OF THE
TOILET AND YOU CAN HAVE
SEVERAL PEOPLE ALL SAYING
WHAT YOU ARE JUST DESCRIBING
HERE WHICH IS THAT HOW
INAPPROPRIATELY SHE WAS
ACTING AND AGGRESSIVELY AND
HOSTILE INITIALLY GOING IN.
AND, LOOK, OBVIOUSLY
EMOTIONS ARE RUNNING HIGH.
ONE OF MY FAVORITE
BEATITUDES ARE BLESSED IS
THE MEEK.
WHO ARE THE MEEK?
THE MEEK ARE THE CHILDREN.
ARE WE RESPONSIBLE FOR
TAKING CARE OF CHILDREN?
WE ARE AT THIS POINT AT THIS
MOMENT.
I THINK WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS FIGURED
OUT YOU HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO TRIAGE THIS
SITUATION.
ONE OF THE THINGS THEY DID
TODAY IS OF ALL THE
IMMIGRATION FIGHTS, THEY
DECIDE WE'RE GOING TO PRINT
THE CENSUS WITHOUT THE
CITIZENSHIP QUESTION.
WHETHER THEY WOULD HAVE WON
ON THE MERITS, I THINK THEY
PROBABLY WOULD HAVE BUT
THERE WAS -- THERE WERE
PROBLEMS WITH IT.
IT IS EXECUTIVE BRANCH'S
RESPONSIBILITY TO DO THE
CENSUS.
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO
GET IT THAT DONE FINE TAKE
IT OFF THE TABLE.
GOT $4.5 BILLION SIGNED LAST
WEEK.
THE PRESIDENT SIGNS IT INTO
LAW.
IT'S NOT EVEN ENOUGH MONEY.
THEY HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HIRE
MORE PEOPLE TO DEAL WHAT SHE
IS TALKING ABOUT.
THEN, THE THIRD THING, IF
YOU ONLY GOT THREE WISHES,
THE THIRD THING HAS TO BE
THIS ASYLUM PIECE.
ON SOME OF THESE MUST-PASS
PIECES OF LEGISLATION THAT
ARE COMING UP IN SEPTEMBER,
I WOULD FOCUS ALL SORTS OF
RESOURCES ON FIGURING OUT A
WAY TO CHANGE THAT.
IF THEY DON'T, I THINK WHAT
GREG IS TALKING ABOUT, THE
CARAVANS AND THE VISUALS,
THEY KNOW THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS UNDER
PRESSURE.
SO THEY ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO SEND PEOPLE
HERE.
AND WE ARE NOT GOING TO HAVE
ENOUGH -- WE ARE NOT
EQUIPPED TO TAKE CARE OF
THEM.
>> Juan: INCENTIVE, DANA, IS
NOT ABOUT ANYTHING THAT WE
SAY OH THESE KIDS ARE NOT
BEING TAKEN CARE OF.
THE INCENTIVE IS THESE
PEOPLE ARE FLEEING
OPPRESSION AND POVERTY AND
WANT BETTER LIFE FOR THEIR
FAMILY AND CHILDREN.
>> Dana: OKAY.
THERE STILL IS A SYSTEM.
EVERYBODY CAN TALK ABOUT HOW
DO YOU FIX THE PROBLEM AT
ITS SOURCE?
THEY DON'T WANT TO LEAVE.
I'M FOR THAT.
>> Greg: OTHER COUNTRIES
SHOULD NOT BE DICTATING OUR
BORDER POLICY BY SENDING
PEOPLE.
WE CANNOT FORGET THAT
CHILDREN ARE BEING USED AND
ABUSED AS PASS KEYS INTO A
COUNTRY WHO BUILT THAT?
THE PEOPLE IN THE UNITED
STATES WHO MOCK THIS
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS MONTHS
AGO.
WE KNOW WHO THEY ARE.
>> Juan: I THINK AOC
DESERVES A TIP OF THE HAT
FOR USING HER TO SHINE A
LIGHT WHAT'S GOING ON DOWN
THERE.